i
you know read up and watched you know um
the evergreen issue with you and then
uh with benjamin post a lot about it
um before i did the podcast with him and
i was just dumbfounded at how that even
happened
at all like but the thing is is i was
like but
brittany you would have been one of
those people
five years six years ago actually
um which is why i always give a hum
i'm not saying for you to do this
because it happened to you so i know
keep going i i try to give
not try i give like this
not grace because who am i but like keep
the empathy tie
with people that i once
was aligned with because i know what you
are
feeling and you actually are usually
questioning yourself because you're
human
and there will be times where i would do
things to where
it wouldn't align with my moral compass
inside but outwardly i'm
i'm putting my fists up but inwardly i'm
like there's some off
and i feel like there's they're i'm not
saying all of them
but there's people over there that know
something's off about this
and the more people have the
conversations about why it's off
the more people are going to start
listening and being like you know what
they're right and i and i have to stop
this but
i would say one thing i did on my
channel
which actually made it which actually
kind of went viral was
i knew that okay so jordan peterson for
instance
i learned about jordan peterson
after the controversy i had no clue who
this man was
didn't know he was a controversial
figure at all
i just came upon a panel he was on
and he specifically just stood out
because i was like wow he's really
challenging um me not necessarily on
race issues just by
critically thinking like that is like
really insightful
how he is thinking about these things
and reframing things i never would have
saw that way and it makes perfect sense
now
so i kept listening to him and listening
and then i stumble across a controversy
that says he's a transphobic
white supremacist i was like i'm like
wait let me see if i put that in google
right because i don't think that's what
they that's not the same man and i'm
like
what what so then i was watching those
videos of people
you know calling him that and chanting
him and shutting
lectures of his down protesting and
i watched the c16 bill all the way
through and him and i was just like
but i would have been those people too
before
i would have went with the mob and the
fact
that i these people are so off
and the fact that i was so off on things
too
i that still dumbfounds me but
long story short i'm a fan of i'm a fan
of him i like him
not to say i love everything like of
course
i don't get everything he says but as a
thinker i think like he
is very important and i did a video
about five things i learned
about um jordan peterson on my channel
and all it said was dear jordan peterson
from a former black lives matter pro and
i knew
i okay yes click bait sue me people
people are trying to live in this world
but but i am
and i knew people were like gonna click
on it because they're like this black
lives matter person is gonna
try to grill jordan and i'm gonna but
all they saw
was me just you know coming in with a
funny intro and being like so i heard
about this guy jordan didn't even bring
up the controversy
didn't just as a man that i just
found as if i didn't know anything about
the controversy at all
and just said i learned this thing and
this thing and this thing and now it has
almost 14 000 views
and almost 50 of the comments are
i was coming here thinking i was going
to defend him and then i left
like sharing this with someone and then
this gives me hope
on this this and and they're like
um we might not align politically but
the fact that
you see who he is
it's just stuff like that i'll do and
and i know that i don't need to say much
the fact that a black woman is talking
about jordan peterson is enough i don't
have to
do his revenge tour like just me
giving that video was me negating the
fact that i don't think he
is someone that hates women and that is
a white supremacist
yeah of course there's people that are
like he's i'm like
go somewhere but stuff like that like
yeah and then yes it it's not easy to do
like everyone's like oh you're so brave
i'm like i don't know if it's bravery
but it's necessary i think
things like that's necessary and
so i do things like that on my channel
and then and then i have another video
about
how tahasi copes with my professor and i
love him people just don't know how to
like wait you like jordan and tom how do
you like them both
like well you can yeah
and maybe you should understand why i do
i went like oh it's a premise right
so yeah so that's that's marvelous
um i there's so many things i want to
say in response i'll try to try to
remember them but
um one thing is it's pretty clear in
your story
that if you had encountered jordan
peterson if you had encountered his
reputation first and then you might not
have even seen his videos
right if you had you know heard that he
was this
vehement white supremacist you might not
have
given him enough of a chance to discover
that actually you got a lot from
his perspective is that fair um
even even with where i am now if i just
came across it i don't i wouldn't go out
on a campaign against them but i would
just click to another video
right definitely i wouldn't yeah so
that's amazing and
very lucky that you encountered stuff in
the order that you did i'm
quite fond of jordan
but the other thing is what i what i
love most about your perspective is that
it's clear
in many of the stories that you've told
that you start from
the evidence or from your experience of
the world
and you reason from it you're not
working backwards from the conclusion
that this that or the other is true and
so you keep arriving at places
that don't align with these stories that
we're being told
and you have the courage to stick with
what you've figured out rather than
be bullied into accepting what the the
crowd is saying
so that's marvelous and you know i also
hear in your
in your story you said you know i mean
amazing
for you to say to me that had you been
at evergreen you probably would have
been
on the other side um but i'm i'm glad
that you did say it and
i you probably have heard from benjamin
when you spoke to him that you know he
and i both have
maintained from the beginning that most
of the people
who were on the so-called other side
were
good people who were confused about what
was going on right
there were some bad people but it was
not a large number it was a tiny number
and they misled a lot of other people
and so you know i take a certain amount
of flack for saying that
people they actually don't like it when
um
when i leave that open and i say you
know good people
acting on bad information that that
feels like
i'm giving more credit than is due but i
know it's not the case
right i know that basically there aren't
you know it'd be hard to accumulate that
many bad people
right these had to be people who were
you know i think
too easily persuaded but nonetheless
people recoverable people people who
aren't you know
intent on doing harm yeah um and so it's
uh
it's actually lovely to hear that from
you that you recognizing yourself that
you would have been on the other side
and that you know and that your your
growth has put you somewhere where you
now see
that that would have been an error
that's great yeah
and encountering jordan in that way
because when i went to
nyu the concentration of my
uh journalism degree was in criticism
so i was already on this journey of
going there and thinking i'm gonna be a
cultural critic yeah but i was
being interrogated by my own way of
thinking
all the time and being challenged and
realizing i needed to get a new vetting
system
on how i looked at stuff but with jordan
was such a stark
um it was it was this evidence of you
have to
wait to make logical sense of something
for yourself before you make a
conclusion
you cannot just go based on the majority
because it was such an example of
the majority of people in a sense you
would say
think this of him and it's objectively
not true like it
and it wasn't a conclusion that i said
when with one video
they're wrong no it actually i would say
about a week i i was looking at stuff
and i'm like yeah i've seen enough this
isn't real like
i but i had but i understood like you
said
the mob if your friends say that's the
enemy
this person's bad you trust your friends
you trust the people that are on your
side that's aligned with you
and you don't ask questions you pick up
your weapon and they're the enemy
and that is the how it goes for the
majority of the time
i feel um
because
there's times for me so let's i don't i
don't know i'm sorry if i'm
going off either you're fine but um
i'll say i made a conclusion about this
person and now we've had zoom calls and
we're i would say
friends i hope he would call me his
friend but um
my my piece free black thought when i
the reason why i i did that
was one that experience with jordan
peterson and other things and
going through my program
made me realize that
people have to really the the art of
critical thinking is
is very important and
not to make assumptions of people um
before
hearing out what's actually the evidence
so coleman hughes when he gave
his speech um at the congressional
hearing against taunting coats this is
when tanahasi was my professor and i
remember being at nyu
and i tuned in and i was rooting for my
professor
and as i was reading for him i saw
coleman i'm like
oh he's he's anti-black he's confused
he's a [ __ ] whatever
but then now
a year ago when i went through all of
this stuff
and really taking myself to task on why
i've come up with conclusions that are
kind of faulty actually
that don't really make sense that i'm
like am i an echo of something or is
this my idea
i went back and i watched that
congressional hearing
and i still thought coats was right in
certain respects but then i listen to
coleman i'm like
and he's for me he's also right they
have different point of views of this
thing and
yeah it's controversial but it's
truthful stings a little but
what he's saying i don't know if it's
all the way wrong and i still agree with
coats and i was just like
wow and i remember writing to coleman
giving him that not knowing what he'd
think because i
in the piece it says i call him a [ __ ]
so i'm like oh i don't know how this is
going to go over
and he was just like wow this is amazing
and he retweeted it and then
everyone saw it and then him and i have
had conversations and
i think also that's what it comes to it
comes to when people realizing
they're wrong and are willing to admit
that
and make amends with it and
hopefully people that
down the line who um mobbed
you to say the least evergreen hopefully
they
come to they reassess that moment
and maybe realize that they were wrong
and
find a way to make it right but
people just don't want to be wrong yeah
people just want to believe what they're
doing is
right because at the end of the day
people want to be good
and and i think everyone's confused on
how
to be good so they go down well
anti-racism
ali i'm going to be the best anti-racist
i'm going to call
everyone and or i'm gonna go down this
way or this way this way
people are trying to find a way to be
good and
not to say we someone has the solution
but
obviously right now we're all confused
yeah and
try to make sense of it that's true i i
say uh the most any of us are is half
awake
so every so often somebody contacts me
and they tell me that they had
they were on the wrong side of the
evergreen
situation and i get apologies from them
and i always tell them i don't need an
apology
as long as you are willing to be honest
with yourself
and others that you were on the wrong
side and
you know that that's good enough that's
that's what i need from people and
um you know so anyway i hope maybe some
will
uh will hear this and think about that
possibility based on
your courage i mean you obviously
weren't there but uh your courage and
modeling
your you know you don't even have to say
what side you would be on and yet you're
courageous enough
to to say that you would have you would
have called it incorrectly
but i also maybe the last thing uh we
should talk about since we've we've been
at this for quite some time
is you know you mentioned tonight coates
[Music]
and coleman hughes and jordan peterson
and i must say these are all people that
i get
something really important from i'm a
huge fan of of coleman's there are a
couple places in which he and i
differ but um overwhelmingly i think
he's
uh he's got it right there are
substantial places where i differ
with tonahisi coats but i will say
our family together read between the
world and me
and we got a lot out of it and
i i i think it's very valid i i don't
see him in the same light as i see
ibram kendy you know or robin deangelo
or
other leaders of this movement who i see
as
either so painfully confused that they
are beyond help uh or cynical
you know but no uh coats is a very
different
very different phenomenon and you know
peterson is
so anyway i guess the point is
interesting
that you and i uh coming from very
different perspectives
land on all of these individuals as uh
simultaneously tapped into the truth at
an important level and not saying the
same thing as each other
right so that tells me something this is
a this is a
worthy list and um i would love to see
more interactions that
allowed their differences to
be sorted out yeah
and and with that
i think people think because if one
likes
you know let's just let's just say
thomas soul they can't like tell nazi
coats
or walt whitman you can't like james
baldwin
for me i don't take anyone as a bible
i don't believe in someone
wholeheartedly
um oftentimes i find that
i look at thinkers and writers and
philosophers
not like the solution to it's almost
like arithmetic like not a solution to
it but like a factor to get to a
solution
because there's so many essays that i've
written
where i will bring in you know
i'll bring in thomas soul but thomas
soul said something that might not be
completely let's just say finnish but
james baldwin actually says something
that helps connect and flush this out
but then coleman said this and then
you know tony morrison said that and
jordan peterson actually said something
about
you know cleaning up your room and this
actually helped like i see it all
as like spices on a rack
in the kitchen and that every spice is
for every dish
but sometimes you need to mix it up
um and so that's how i see thinkers
and i don't i don't think because you're
on
a side or this side i think the whole
side thing is arbitrary and the binary
needs to be squashed
so i don't even think of it like that i
i just
read something and if i get something on
this person and i realize they have a
lot to give
then they go on my shelf and i pull them
off if i need to pull them off
and they might be completely polarizing
in ideas
but the thing is is sometimes they're
looking at the same thing from different
angles
and then i'm adding my angle and that's
actually filling out and flushing out
the issue
more and seeing it through one lens
yep you know i actually i got this from
your
uh your tablet piece about the
debate between booker t washington and
w.e.b du bois
just i must tell you i was completely
unaware at a historical level
about the two positions
and the conflict between them and
frankly it's funny we're almost having
the very same
discussion to this day about you know
it's sort of a
personal responsibility versus uh
you know active correctives
and uh and you know
it ain't one or the other there's a
nuanced conversation to be had
about what the right admixture is
um but we're not having that
conversation because of as you point out
the polarization
so anyway i would suggest that uh people
who are interested to check out your
article in in tablet magazine which is
available
online
[Music]
you